- Welcome back, everyone,
to my channel here on Firm Learning.
This is the Christmas
edition of Firm Learning.
So welcome to another coffee break indeed,
and Merry Christmas to all of you.
I feel honored that today I
have my sister with me here.
- Yes, hi. I'm Carolina.
I'm Heinrich's sister,
and I'm joining him for this new video.
I'm excited.
- The first time on the channel,
So it's a pleasure, Carolina.
Please be nice to her in the comments,
because what we have
planned here for today
is a little Christmas edition,
a person in edition.
I hope that this would help
you better get to know me,
and also the other way around
if we have some conversations
about this in the comments.
Because what I asked you
to do on the Instagram
is to ask me a couple
of personal questions,
personal things that you would
like to know about myself.
and I screenshotted all the answers
and sent them to Carolina,
so she has them all on her phone now.
And so I trust she will now
pick a couple of the questions
that you sent me,
and let's see what I will answer to that.
And Carolina, you agree that
you didn't tell him in advance
what questions these will be, right?
- No, I didn't tell him in advance,
so it's gonna be a
little surprise for him.
- Surprise, surprise.
So let's go.
- So let's start.
- Indeed.
- First question,
"Who inspires you for your
success and creativity?"
- Oh, that's a good one.
And here, frankly,
I think there many
people who do inspire me,
probably both on the personal
and on the professional side.
So I had the pleasure to work
with some extremely
inspirational, motivational people
over the course of my
career over the last years.
And I don't wanna say any specific names,
but there were several past colleagues
or some project leads of
mine, partners of mine,
that I worked with,
and that I really enjoyed
working with a lot.
Some other friends of mine
who I meet at university
who I regularly see,
founded some startups, other careers,
are some very inspirational people.
And for sure, lots of things
that have come from these
gentlemen and ladies in the past.
- How did your first marathon go?
- My first marathon was, I believe,
2017 or 2018 or so in Paris.
So I ran the marathon in Paris there.
I wasn't much of a runner before.
The furthest thing that I could
do were maybe 10 kilometers
or something like that.
But that was quite a stretch for me.
And then it was actually
my wife who motivated me
to do a half marathon.
She was always much more of
a runner than I always was.
And so then I remember
that about a year before this marathon,
we signed up for a half
marathon in Munich,
and I managed to do that then as well.
And then I got some confidence
that probably if I could
do the half marathon,
I would also be able to
then run the extra marathon.
And so over the course of a year,
I did some training, practiced.
And in the end, yes, I made it in Paris.
And then one year later I
ran the marathon in Munich.
And then I wanted to
then also the year after
do another marathon.
So my idea was to run
my one marathon a year,
but then the whole health
situation prevented that.
And then the marathon got canceled.
Now, frankly, I'm a
little bit out of shape.
So probably for the New Year
resolutions for next year,
this is one of the
things I need to tackle.
- So how many marathons
did you do in total now?
- Two.
- Two, okay.
- But Carolina, I know
that you are also currently
running a lot yourself,
so probably some things that
I should learn from you again,
inspired from you.
- But pretty far away
from a marathon, I think.
- Baby steps.
- Yes.
So you spoke about your wife already.
So now the question
I think everyone was kind
of asking themselves,
how did you find your wife?
- Yeah, so I'm together with my now wife
already for many, many years.
I met her in the beginning of university,
and it was actually on Odeonsplatz,
which was quite a big place.
Everybody from Munich would know it.
And I met her actually after Oktoberfest.
So I was on Oktoberfest,
you know how this goes.
Like leather trousers,
some beer and so on.
And then after, once we left,
and then we were on on Odeonsplatz
and then I saw a random group
of ladies standing there.
I was with some friends myself as well.
And then we approached them,
and this is how I got to know my now wife.
- So you just talked to her.
- I just talked to her with
a little bit of confidence
from drinking the one or
other Mass at Oktoberfest.
The locals know what I'm talking about.
That gave me then the confidence
to approach them and talk to her.
And yes, many, many years ago.
And then two or three years
ago now, we got married.
- So how many years ago was that?
- In 2019.
- 2019. Nice.
It's a German question.
So "Which topic are you
educating yourself on currently?"
- So that's a good question.
And I mean, during my current
role at Building Radar
where I currently work as
a chief revenue officer,
one of the topics that now
I'm focusing more about,
which of course also heavily relates
to what I do at Firm
Learning, is online marketing.
So I'm currently learning a
lot about online marketing,
copywriting, creating sales
funnels, sales structures.
This of course is a big,
important topic also
for Building Radar and what we do here
at Firm Learning as well.
So yeah, currently lots of books
under my bed about these topics.
- And you like to listen to them, right?
- Some are also on Audible.
This is a service that
I use to listen to them,
but some also in the
written, printed book format.
- Nice.
"What brings you joy in life?"
- Oh, wow.
That's a philosophical question.
And even though I did study
philosophy many, many years ago
and I have a Bachelor of Philosophy,
I think this is a question
that's often very difficult to answer.
But in my specific situation,
given that this year
our baby girl was born,
the answer is of course quite easy.
So we feel so blessed
that since April actually of this year,
we have a baby girl that's
part of our young family.
And of course, she brings
us joy every single day,
even though it's of
course not always easy.
It's sometimes also quite tiring.
She's more than making up for that.
- "What have you learned about yourself
since having your daughter?"
- What do you think about that?
Did they change in any way
since I have a daughter?
- Not really, I think.
I think you're still the same.
Not much, actually. No.
- Yeah, I mean, it's an
interesting question.
So do we change because
we become children?
I mean, surely your priorities shift,
and surely this is a new,
big responsibility of course
that you have in your life.
And surely now, you have
to think about new things
that you didn't need to
think about in the past.
So a couple of days before,
we decided to actually take the train here
to the west of Germany.
Our girl was sick, so we wondered,
can we now do the train ride
because she wasn't feeling well.
And thankfully she recovered in time.
Of course, this is a
new layer of complexity
that we didn't have before.
But I must say, beyond these
smallest, obvious things,
I don't feel like life
completely changed for me
to be honest now.
- "What's your advice on work-life balance
and balancing career
aspirations with family needs?"
- I mean, here for sure,
this is one of the things
where your perspective does change also
after you become children.
So I remember when I was
working in consulting,
it was very common for
me, no problem at all,
to obviously work late in the evenings.
I remember my first internship
that I did in consulting,
I spend with the team in the office.
That was like the first or second day.
And then around 7:00 or 8:00 PM,
we decided to go for some dinner.
I thought, yeah, sure, why not?
Let's have some dinner with the team.
And then I was eating something.
And then I must say I was
a little bit surprised
that then after dinner,
everyone was going back to the team room.
So we were going back to the team room.
We continuing to work there.
Probably this was just
a sign of my ignorance,
that I didn't inform myself enough
before I applied for this
consulting internship.
But at that time, that was normal.
It wasn't a problem at all for me.
And frankly, I know many
people also with family
than decide to continue this career path.
but the truth is of course
that many people also,
once they get children,
then at some point decide
that maybe this is the time
to spend a little bit more
time at home with your family,
with their children.
Because of course it's great
to see them during the week,
see them in the evenings.
And this was not the main
reason why I left the firm,
the consulting firm,
because that was already
when I didn't have a child.
But surely now, thinking back
at when I was still working in consulting
or having a child at the same time,
that that would have been quite difficult.
- So then this is like
three questions in one.
First, "What drives you?"
Second, "What are your pillars?"
And three, "How do these pillars
impact you and your decisions?"
- Here probably also the truth
is it's not that I have these
big drivers where I could say,
this is why I do the things that I do.
The pillars, if you mean this,
like the virtues, the
values that drive you,
so here I think I would struggle.
But one thing that I really liked,
it's part of an organization
I was part of as a student.
In German, you say, (in foreign language).
I feel like this is quite
a strong group of words.
So (in foreign language) means probably-
- Performance.
(in foreign language)
means drive, initiative.
And (in foreign language)
means responsibility.
I find these three pretty
good and sound principles
that you wanna follow.
So of course the things that you do
you wanna do well, performance.
you don't just wanna do the things
that you are asked to do,
but also have some
initiative, be proactive.
Think about, try to be yourself.
What are the things that
you wanna shape and build
and create in your life?
And then third, of course, responsibility.
At some point, that's the question.
I are responsible of course
for your family, for society.
Can you transform the things that you do
to become the force
for good, in any sense?
I think these are questions
very well worth to be inquired.
- Nice. Something I
can learn here as well.
- (faintly speaking) that you can.
- "Your Patagonia vest,
which one do you recommend?"
- So I think yesterday I
posted an Instagram Story,
and then I got some questions
on this new Patagonia vest.
Indeed, my wife gave this to
me as a Christmas present.
So see here, I'm not
sure if you can see it,
the sort of Firm Learning embroidery here.
So I like Patagonia vests quite a lot,
but I feel like at some point,
especially over the last one or two years,
I'm a bit afraid they
became even more of a cliche
than they already were a cliche.
So I'm not sure if I can really continue.
- Maybe you shake the cliche.
I'm not trying.
- I don't know, but I
think they look cool.
It's also really nice under a suit, maybe.
Also in the team room in
consulting, just to stay warm.
Then at some point you can take away
like the upper part of your suit,
and then just wear a
dress shirt with the vest.
This is something that is
very well accepted also,
like in the big consulting firms.
Also, if you work client-side,
but some, maybe a bit
more comfortable and comfy
than maybe the more
traditional suit setup.
So I like this.
And probably this is also the reason
that many other people like this as well.
- "What's the best advice you would give
to a business student coming
from your experience?"
Maybe personal advice?
- I guess it's probably important to,
and given that I know that many
people watching this channel
are interested in consulting,
it's important to probably
understand rather early
that this is a pathway that you wanna do.
Because surely if your goal
is to join one of the big
leading consulting firms,
you need to really move in that direction
as fast as possible.
So I mean, this has to do with grades
that you need to write,
so some level of academic performance.
This has to do with some
internships that you need to make.
Also, the right cadence of internships.
I mean, you do need to transform
also your curriculum vitae,
your pathway in the direction.
And this level of activities
and of performance
is maybe not needed if
you are also interested
in another career path.
So probably, it's really
about understanding
what you want to do rather early on,
and then moving in that way.
And then of course,
there are many other
things you can do as well,
if for whatever reason this
is not what you want to do.
And I guess that's also very fair,
and you can have a fantastic
and fulfilling career
following some of these
other paths as well.
- I think that's it.
Because there were a lot of
obviously career questions.
Should you do an MBA? Career advice.
And we don't wanna cover-
- Lets keep it personal for this one.
So many more questions to
cover in the following Q&As.
So thanks for joining.
I guess, that's it, Carolina, right?
- That's it. Thank you
Very much for watching.
- Thank you very much.
Looking forward to many more
videos with you, Carolina.
Let me know in the comments
whether you wanna have more videos
with Carolina in the future.
Thanks to all the members
of Firm Learning as well.
I will include the names here somewhere.
Merry Christmas to all of you.
Enjoy the festive period,
and a good start to the new year.
And I'm looking forward
to many, many more helpful
videos in the new year.
So stay tuned for that.
All the best.
New videos on this channel
every single Saturday.
Cheers.
- Bye-bye. Subscribe.
(both laughing)